today we're talking about The Unofficial
GTA 6 map and the feature that Call of
Duty players want back
following years of GTA 5 Grand Theft
Auto fans are extremely thirsty for any
information on the next game in the
series this thirst is so deep that not
even the massive leak from earlier this
week was able to keep some satisfied and
believe it or not I did not realize how
much that rhymed when I first wrote it
but bars so while Rockstar has been busy
sweeping the internet clean of any early
gameplay fans have been busy piecing
together a map of GTA 6's location based
on Clues from that leaked footage this
project is reminiscent of a fan made GTA
5 map created by GTA Forum users who use
the game's promotional footage and
screenshots to get an early view of Los
Santos This Time Around The Bare Bones
map is being created using in-game
coordinates displayed in the leak to
figure out where each location sits in
relation to the rest of them these
cartographers have had to get creative
in order to get around Rockstar's
copyright restrictions with much of the
main GT EA forms discussions working
around how to most accurately map the
leaked content without including images
that can't be posted in the community
other projects hosted outside of the
forums have more complete maps in the
works including mini map segments taken
from the leaked footage as well as the
more concrete details taken from the
leaks until Rockstar releases more
official material on the game the map
making efforts aren't likely to get much
further than basic speculation from what
fans have already uncovered it's looking
like GTA 6 will have a huge world to
explore with a map at least as big or
bigger than GTA 5's Los Santos Switching
gears to Call of Duty now modern warfare
2's beta is in full swing and one of the
Hot Topics players are discussing is the
lack of nameplates above enemies with
many calling for the feature to return
in the name of improving visibility in
previous Call of Duty titles enemy
players would have their name displayed
in red above their heads that's not the
case in in Modern Warfare 2's beta where
players have reported regularly shooting
at their own teammates due to it being
unclear who is and who isn't an enemy
though teammates do have blue nameplates
they are hard to parse especially in
some of the game's darker areas making
it confusing when attempting to
distinguish friend from foe those dark
areas also make it difficult to see
enemies which is something that enemy
nameplates would help alleviate players
are confused if the lack of nameplates
is intentional or some kind of bug there
is an option in the game's menu to
display enemy markers as red despite
those markers not yet appearing in the
game however judging from Infinity War's
recent comments it seems like the lack
of enemy nameplates is a conscious
choice and not a mistake Infinity Ward
alluded to the issue in a recent blog
post about changes coming to Modern
Warfare 2's beta for its second weekend
stating it is investigating more ways to
visually differentiate enemies from
friendlies outside of the standard name
place above heads of the opposing
players that beta I've been talking
about this whole time returns to
PlayStation today for all players and
also on Xbox and PC for those who have
pre-ordered all platforms will have open
access to the beta from the 24th to the
26th so if you're interested make sure
to jump on this weekend give the game a
try I've been playing it on PlayStation
and it feels good it feels really good
I'm I'm way more excited to jump in
mouse and keyboard because that's when
I'm I'm really like sick with it you
know I'm clicking heads left and right
and you don't want to see me you don't
want to see me in those lobbies
all right I'm not that good
I'm okay I'm average